this won't end until one of them submits  they have an ancient rivalry godzilla  will come for him  we need kong the world needs him  kong may be our only owner  should save our world  godzilla vs kong in theaters and on hbo  max the exact same day waited pg-13  i know gia is only a child she's the  only one he'll communicate with  and we need kong  here we go this won't end until one of  them submits  are you sure the monkey's going to  survive this it's us i'd worry  my about this is so massive  godzilla versus call in theaters and on  hbo max march 31st rated pg-13  we need calm the world needs him  godzilla will comfort him  in theaters and on hbo max the exact  same day rated pg-13  you